can you explain how that's
possible to tie together so many
problems
in a nice bunch that if one is proven to
be efficient
then all are the first uh
and most important stage of progress was
a result by
stephen cook
who showed that a certain problem called
the satisfiability problem
of propositional logic
is as hard as any problem in the class p
so the propositional logic problem
is expressed in terms of
expressions involving the logical
operations
and or and not offering operating
operating on variables that can be
either true or false
so an instance of the problem would be
some formula involving and or and not
and the question would be whether there
is an assignment of
truth values to the variables in the
problem
that would make the formula true so for
example if i take
the formula a or b
and a or not b and not a or b
and not a or not b and take the
conjunction of all four of those
so-called expressions you can determine
that
no assignment of truth values to the
variables a and b
will allow that conjunction of
cl what are called clauses uh to be true
so that's an example of a formula
in propositional logic
involving expressions based on the
operations and or and not
um that's an example of a problem which
has which is not satisfiable there is no
solution that satisfies all of those
constraints
and that's like one of the cleanest and
fundamental problems in computer science
it's like a nice statement of a really
hard problem it's a nice statement a
really hard problem
and and what cook showed is that
every problem in np
is can be re-expressed as
an instance of the satisfiability
problem
so to do that
he used the observation that a very
simple abstract machine called the
turing machine
can be used to describe
any algorithm a
an algorithm for any realistic computer
can be translated
into an equivalent algorithm
on uh one of these turing machines which
are extremely simple
it's a tour machine there's a tape and
you can yeah
you have to walk along that data on a
tape and you have basic instructions
a finite list of instructions which say
we
would say if you're reading a particular
symbol on the tape
and you're in a particular state then
you can move to
a different state and change the state
of the number that you
or the element that you were looking at
the cell of the tape that you were
looking at
and that was like a metaphor and a
mathematical construct that
touring put together to represent all
possible computation
all possible computation now one of
these so-called turing machines is too
simple to be useful
in practice but for theoretical purposes
we can
depend on the fact that an algorithm for
any computer can be translated into one
that would run
on a turing machine right and then
using that fact um he could
sort of describe
um any possible non-deterministic
polynomial time algorithm any
any algorithm for a problem in np
could be expressed as a sequence of
moves of the turing machine described in
terms of
reading a symbol on the tape
while you're in a given state and moving
to a new state and leaving behind a new
new symbol and given that
the fact that any non-deterministic
polynomial time algorithm can be
described by a list of such instructions
you could translate the problem
into the language of the satisfiability
problem
is that amazing to you by the way if you
take yourself back when you were first
thinking about the space of problems is
that
how amazing is that it's astonishing
when you look at cook's proof it's not
too difficult to
sort to figure out why this is
why this is so but the implications are
staggering
it tells us that this of all the
problems
in np all the problems where solutions
are easy to check
they can they can all be rewritten
in terms of uh the satisfiability
problem
yes in adding so much more
weight to the p equals np
question because all it takes is to show
that one
that's right one algorithm in this class
so the p versus np
can be re-expressed as simply asking
whether the satisfiability problem of
propositional logic
you'll solve a billion polynomial time
but there's more um
i i encountered cook's paper when he
published it in a conference in 1971.
yeah so when i saw uh cook's paper
and saw this uh reduction
event of all of each of the problems in
np
by a uniform method to to the
satisfiability problem of propositional
logic
that meant that the satisfiability
problem was a universal combinatorial
problem
and it occurred to me
through experience i had had in trying
to solve other combinatorial problems
that there were many other problems
which
seemed to have that universal structure
and so i began looking for
reductions from the satisfiability
to other problems
one of the other problems would be the
so-called integer programming problem of
solving a determining whether there's a
solution to
a a set of
linear inequalities involving integer
variables
just like linear programming but there's
a constraint that the variables must
remain integers integers in fact must be
either zero or one
because they could only take on those
values and that makes the problem much
harder
yes that makes the problem much harder
and
um it was not difficult to show
that the satisfiability problem can be
restated
as an integer programming problem so can
you pause on that was that one of the
first pro
mappings that you tried to do and how
hard is that map but you said it wasn't
hard to show but
you know that's a that's a big
leap it is a big leap yeah
well let me let me give you another
example um
another problem uh in np is whether
a graph contains a clique of a given
size
and now the question is
can we reduce the propositional logic
problem
to the problem of
whether there's a clique of a certain
size
well if you look at the propositional
logic problem it can be expressed as a
number of
clauses each of which is
a
of the form a
or b or c where a is either one of the
variables in the problem
or the negation of one of the variables
and the
an instance of the propositional logic
problem
can be rewritten using operations of
boolean logic can be
re rewritten as the conjunction of a set
of clauses
the and of a set of ors where each
clause
is a disjunction an or
of variables or negated variables
so the question of
in the satisfiability problem is whether
those clauses can be simultaneously
satisfied
now to satisfy all those clauses you
have to find
one of the terms in each clause
which is going to be given the which is
going to be true in your truth
assignment
but you can't make the same variable
both true and false
so if you have the variable a in one
clause
and you want to satisfy that clause by
making a
true you can't also make the complement
of a
true in some other clause and so the
goal is to make every single clause
true if it's possible to satisfy this
and
the way you make it true is at least one
term in the clause must be
it must be true so
so now we to convert this problem
to something called the independent set
problem where you're
just sort of asking for a set of
vertices in a graph such that no two of
them are adjacent sort of the opposite
of the clique problem
so we've seen that we can now
express that as
finding a
set of terms one in each clause
without picking both the variable
and the negation of that variable
because you if the variable is assigned
the truth value
the negated variable has to have the
opposite truth value
right and so we can construct the graph
where the vertices are the
terms in all of the clauses
and you have an edge
between two um
terms if um
an edge between two occurrences of terms
either if they're both in the same
clause because you're only picking
one element from each clause
and also an edge between them if they
represent
opposite values of the same variable
because you can't make a variable both
true and false and so you get a graph
where you have all of these occurrences
of variables
you have edges which which mean that
you're not allowed to choose
both ends of the edge either because
they're in the same clause or they're
con negations of one another right and
that's a
first sort of to zoom out that's a
really powerful idea that you can take
a graph and connect it to a
logic equation right somehow and do the
mapping for
all possible formulations of a
particular problem on a graph
yeah i mean that that
still is hard for me to believe that
that's possible
that that they're like what do you make
of that
that um there's such a union of
there's such a friendship among all
these problems across
that somehow are akin to combinatorial
uh algorithms that they're all somehow
related
yeah i i know it can be proven yeah but
what do you make of it
that that that's true
well that they just have the same
expressive power you can take
any one of them and translate it into
the terms of the other
you know the fact that they have the
same expressive power also somehow
means that they can be translatable
right
and what i did in the 1971 paper was to
take
21 fundamental problems
the commonly occurring problems of
packing covering matching and so forth
or lying in the class np
and show that the satisfiability problem
can be
re-expressed as any of those that any of
those have the same
expressive proper uh expressive power
so and that was like throwing down the
gauntlet of saying
there's probably many more problems like
this right but that's just
saying that look that they're all the
same they're all the same
but not exactly they're all the same in
terms of
whether they are um
rich enough to express any of the others
um but that doesn't mean that they have
the same computational complexity
but what we can say is that either
all of these problems or none of them
are solvable in polynomial time
yeah so where does np completeness and
np
hard classes oh that's just a small
technicality
so when we're talking about decision
problems
that means that the answer is just yes
or no
there is a clique of size 15 or there's
not a clique of size 15.
on the other hand an optimization
problem would be asking
um find the largest clique the answer
would not be yes or no it would be
15. so
so when you're asking for the
when you're putting a valuation on the
different solutions
then you're asking for the one with the
highest valuation that's an optimization
problem and there's a very close
affinity between the two kinds of
problems
but the counterpart of
being the hardest decision problem
the hardest yes no problem the current
part of that
uh is is to minimize or maximize
an objective function and so a problem
that's
hardest in the class when viewed in
terms of optimization
those are called np hard rather than
np-complete and mpcomplete is for
decision problems and np-complete is for
decision problems
you